benillouche c'est les journalistes
indépendants bonjour à vous merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
qu'implique l'accord prévu entre israël
les émirats arabes unis alors l'accord
implique certainement leur projet de
report de l'annexion de certaines
implantations en israël en cisjordanie
alors l'extrême droite est contente
parce que l'annexion ne l'intéressait
pas et les peaux parce qu'elle unis
voulaient une annexion total de la
cisjordanie or le projet de trains
impliqués l'élection partielle de
certaines implantations donc aujourd'hui
la l'extrême droite est heureuse elle
est d'autre part 7,7
cette décision va un peu regoûter un
petit peu le l'état de l'opinion
israélienne et de hainaut américaine
parce que ça va redorer le blason de
trump qui est en difficulté dans les
sondages sont en baisse et qui n'a
jamais réussi à obtenir quoi que ce soit
de positif dans le problème
israélo-palestinien donc ceci va lui
permettre éventuellement de remonter un
petit peu dans les sondages
quentin natanyahou et bien il va
effectivement aussi remonter dans les
sondages parce qu'une partie de son de
son électoral parti à l'extrême droite
parce qu'il refusait la détention
et comme il n'y aura pas d'élection et
bien cette extrême droite va revenir au
licou donc tout le monde va trouver son
compte et nous allons avoir
effectivement une situation nouvelle
mais qui n'est pas cette cette décision
département nouvelle en israël parce que
vous savez en 2012
natanyahou avait rencontré le ministre
des affaires étrangères du des émirats à
new york dans un hôtel au vu et au su de
tout le monde donc on savait que il y
avait quelque chose qui se trame est la
seule la seule inconnue qui existent
enregistrait c'était de savoir quel
était le pays qui le premier allait
prendre les décès des mesures annoncées
qu'il ya le conseil de coopération du
golfe le ccg qui comprend l'arabie
séoudite parraine l'eau mal
les émirats et le qatar alors on pensé
pendant longtemps que le qatar serait le
premier pays qui avaient signé des
accords avec israël
le qatar on sait qu'en 2010 lord le le
chef du qatar était venue en israël
secrètement rencontré madame type il est
unique et l ancienne ambassadrice
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères et qui était à ce moment là
chef de l'opposition il est élu l'a
rencontré à jérusalem
donc vous pensez que derrière cette
visite il y allait avoir un il y avait à
voir éventuellement des relations nouées
mais le hsv déluge s'agissant du projet
d'injection des territoires palestiniens
benyamin nétanyahou ne renonce pas pour
autant c'était une suspension donc est
ce que c'est c'est ce projet est à
l'abandon réellement comme je pense
qu'il le pourra pas le faire parce qu'il
s'est engagé effectivement avec les
américains il s'est engagé avec les
émirats alors il veut calmer un petit
peu un petit peu son opinion de droite
mais je pense que de toute façon ça
avait pris du plomb dans l aile
cette annexion d'abord parce que
l'extrême droite est pas content et donc
je vois pas comment il peut se mettre en
opposition avec son extrême droite quand
même un projet qui est décriée par un
les palestiniens et on voit quand les
l'autorité palestinienne dénonce une
trahison à travers cet accord une
trahison de la part des émirats arabes
unis
comment vous vous l'interprétez je pense
que les palestiniens ont toujours raté
une occasion de gagner une occasion ils
ont toujours hâte et je pense que cette
occasion là est une occasion qui va père
qui aurait permis éventuellement
d'ouvrir des relations d'ouvrir des
discussions d'intégrer et palestiniens
au sein d'une discussion au sein d'une
négociation
ils en sont exclus et c'est encore une
autre occasion de rater la part des
palestiniens
je pense que le fait de condamner
systématiquement cet accord de paix
n'est pas positif d'autant plus que les
pays arabes ont 1 1 ont maintenant un
danger fondamentale avec l'iran donc la
palestine ne les intéresse plus le
blême palestiniens ne les intéresse plus
donc si la palestine se met à l'écart
ll sera perdante moi je pense que il
faut que les palestiniens révisent leurs
attitudes et dans le fond c'est celle de
rentrer nord en le dans le dialogue de
paix parce que c'est un véritable
dialogue de paix qui va s'instaurer
et je pense que dans le cadre de ce
dialogue il pourrait obtenir plus que
s'il avait une chaise vide
dans le cas contraire quelles sont les
conséquences de cet accord sur les
tensions au proche orient
je pense que pour l'instant si on voit
le nord le hezbollah est complètement
éteint aujourd'hui à la suite de ce qui
s'est passé une explosion poliment
d'onde dense au niveau du nord
le hezbollah n'est pas en état de
manifester n'est pas en état
d'intervenir quant au sud à gaza eh bien
ils ne sont pas non plus intéressés à en
créer des problèmes pour eux ils sont
pas ils n'ont pas été intégrés dans ces
discussions sur l'annexion ils n'en
veulent pas et donc ils veulent tout à
fait être à l'écart de ces négociations
ils veulent ils ne veulent pas que les
palestiniens que l'âme mahmoud abbas
prenne le dessus et reprennent la
direction éventuellement de gaza donc
pour eux ils ne sont pas prêts à faire
éventuellement à faire des troubles si
on envoie quelques troubles à l'heure
actuelle c'est pas contre israël
c'est pour marquer leur présence parce
qu'il veut faire comprendre au qatar qui
doit normalement arrêté dans quelque
temps dans quelques mois de verser de
l'argent au payer les salaires des
jambes de gaza c'est de faire comprendre
aux gens de 2,2 du qatar que s'il
arrêtait les lieux de remises de fonds
et biens y aurait des problèmes donc ça
s'adresse pas à israël ça s'adresse au
qatar pour leur dis continuez à nous
aider nous sommes dans la parade
nous avons besoin que vous leur le
l'autorité palestinienne ne nous sert
plus l'argent ne nous de ne plus rien et
si vous arrêtez et bien il y aura des
troubles et c'est pour ça qu'ils veulent
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste indépendant